"SEEN AND UNSEEN."
BUT FIRST, JOE’S FANTASY COVID
TO FIX.
THAT IS THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT’S
"ANGLE."
JOE BIDEN MADE A RARE APPEARANCE
TONIGHT TO ANSWER SOFTBALL
QUESTIONS.
>> WALK US WHAT YOU WOULD DO
DIFFERENTLY AND ASSUMING
ACTUALLY IT’S BY THEN WILL BE
WORSE.
>> I DON’T KNOW HOW BAD IT IS
GOING TO BE.
IT WILL HAVE TO BE WORSE BECAUSE
HE’S NOT DEALING WITH ANYTHING
HE SAID WOULD GO AWAY.
IT’S GOING TO BE WORSE.
I SPEAK WITH DOXXED THREE TIMES
A WEEK SOMETIMES FOUR TIMES A
WEEK AN HOUR AND 15 MINUTES.
THEY PREDICT AMONG THEM THAT
THERE WILL BE 200,000 DEAD BY
THE TIME WE GET TO ELECTION DAY.
THEY PREDICT THIS WILL JUST GET
WORSE AND WORSE.
>> Laura: TRANSLATION: BIDEN
SAYS TRUMP BAD ON COVID, VIRUS
BAD, SO TRUMP PLUS VIRUS IS
WORSE.
>> IF I’M FORTUNATE ENOUGH TO BE
LIKE THE PRESIDENT, WE WILL HAVE
TO TAKE SIGNIFICANT ACTION TO DO
A NUMBER OF THINGS.
ONE, YOU NEED MORE TESTING.
YOU NEED TO BE ABLE TO TEST AND
TRACE.
YOU NEED TO BE IN A POSITION
WHERE YOU ARE ABLE TO ASSIST
EVERYONE TO WEAR A MASK AND
EVERYONE SOCIALLY DISTANCE.
THAT BUSINESS DO NOT OPEN IF
THEY CANNOT DO THAT.
WE NEED TO KEEP PEOPLE ON THEIR
FEET.
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE HEALTH
INSURANCE AS WE HAVE HEALTH
INSURANCE AS WELL AS MAKING SURE
NO ONE HAS TO PAY FOR
CONTRACTING COVID AND/OR BEING
TREATED FOR COVID TO.
>> Laura: WELL, HOW MANY OF
YOU THINK THAT IS REALISTIC?
NO ONE EVER HAS TO PAY FOR
ANYTHING!
IS HE EVEN AWARE THAT WE’VE DONE
MORE TESTING THAN ANY NATION ON
EARTH?
AS OF TODAY, WE’VE DONE
48.6 MILLION COVID TESTS IN THE
UNITED STATES.
THERE IS NO INDICATION AT ALL
THAT BIDEN COULD DO ANYMORE ANY
FASTER, AT LEAST WE HAVEN’T SEEN
ANY EVIDENCE OF THAT.
SO THAT IS ALL BUNK.
SO WHAT IS LEFT?
ROLLING SHUTDOWNS OR A COMPLETE
NATIONAL SHUTDOWN UNTIL THE
VIRUS MAGICALLY DISAPPEARS.
AND WE OPENED UP TOO SOON.
WE DIDN’T HAVE THE VIRUS TOTALLY
UNDER CONTROL.
YOU JUST HAVE TO SHUT DOWN FOR
NOW.
I THINK THAT GOD IS OUR ONLY WAY
OUT.
>> IF YOU LEAPFROG OVER
DIFFERENT PHASES, YOU INCREASE
THE RISK THAT YOU WILL HAVE THE
KIND OF RESURGENCE IS THAT WE
ARE SEEING.
>> HOW MUCH WORSE DOES IT HAVE
TO GET IN LOS ANGELES BEFORE YOU
FEEL COMPELLED TO ISSUE ANOTHER
STAY AT HOME ORDER?
>> SURE, WELL, I THINK WE ARE ON
THE BRINK OF THAT.
>> Laura: I SAID THIS LAST
WEEK.
I FULLY EXPECT BY OCTOBER, ALL
BLUE STATES IN THE UNITED STATES
WILL EITHER BE SHUT DOWN OR ON
THE WAY TO SHUTDOWN.
AND OF COURSE, WE HAVE TRIED
SHUTTING DOWN ALL ACROSS
AMERICA, AND THE VIRUS IS
OBVIOUSLY STILL THERE.
MEANWHILE, WE LOST MILLIONS AND
MILLIONS OF JOBS.
NOW, DIDN’T TAKE THE
HEAVY-HANDED APPROACH AND
BASICALLY THROUGH THE WORST OF
IT.
LET’S GO ON TO TRACING AND
TRACKING.
THIS MEANS AMONG OTHER THINGS
THAT THE GOVERNMENT FORCES YOU
TO DOWNLOAD AN APP ON YOUR PHONE
THAT KEEPS YOU MONITORED IF YOU
TEST POSITIVE.
NOW, HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
PAID TRACKERS -- IT’S LIKE A NEW
TSA FOR THE VIRUS TO ROAM AROUND
THE COUNTRY TO KEEP US SAFE.
YOU KNOW, TO THAT I SAY, WHY
DOESN’T NEW YORK AND CALIFORNIA
SHOW US HOW GREAT THEY ARE
TRACING AND TRACKING THEM?
WHAT IS STOPPING THEM FROM
SHOWING EVERYONE HOW WELL IT
WORKS?
AND FINALLY I’M ON THE MASK
QUESTION, BIDEN SOUNDS LIKE HE
WOULD ISSUE SOME SORT OF I GUESS
FEDERAL RULE MANDATING MASKS FOR
THE FORESEEABLE FUTURE FOREVER
FOR ALL WE KNOW.
MAY BE EVERYWHERE EXCEPT WHEN
YOU ARE IN YOUR OWN HOME WITH
YOUR FAMILY.
THAT IS HARD TO SEE ANY OF THAT
IS CONSTITUTIONAL.
AS WE TOLD YOU LAST WEEK, THE
SCIENCE ON CLOTH MASKS IS VERY
MURKY.
THAT IS PUTTING IT CHARITABLY.
BUT NEVERTHELESS PRESIDENT TRUMP
IS EMBRACING THEM, AND THEY MAY
MAKE SOME PEOPLE FEEL BETTER AND
MORE PATRIOTIC SO THAT IS FINE.
BUT LET’S GET REAL HERE.
IF THERE WERE A MAGIC DEMOCRATIC
SOLUTION TO THE VIRUS,
GOVERNOR GAVIN NEWSOM IN
CALIFORNIA GRETCHEN WHITMER AND
MICHIGAN WOULD HAVE BEEN
BRAGGING ABOUT IT BY NOW.
AND ANDREW CUOMO NURSING HOME
WOULDN’T BE KILLING FIELDS.
RATHER THAN ACKNOWLEDGING THAT
THERE ARE REAL TRADE-OFFS IN
FIGHTING THE VIRUS, THE LEFT IS
LIVING IN LA LOVELAND.
BECAUSE THEY ACT LIKE SHUTTING
DOWN AND DOING IT AGAIN AND
AGAIN AND AGAIN HAS ZERO
CONSEQUENCE.
THROWING PEOPLE UNDER THE
UNEMPLOYMENT ROLLS HOWEVER WE
KNOW HAS MAJOR CONSEQUENCES.
MANY OF THE SMALL BUSINESSES ARE
BARELY HOLDING ON AS IT IS.
AND NOW THEY ARE HAVING TO HOLD
OUT DON’T MAKE THE RUG PULLED
OUT FROM UNDERNEATH THEM AGAIN.
PAIN COMES IN MANY FORMS, WE ALL
KNOW THAT BUT INSTEAD OF
RECOGNIZING IT, THIS IS A
TRAGEDY CAUSED BY TRAINING AND
ONE NEITHER REPUBLICANS OR
DEMOCRATS COULD EASILY SOLVE MY
DEMOCRATS AND THEIR MEDIA
PLAYING ELECTION YEAR POLITICS
AND I GUESS IT’S TO BE EXPECTED,
BUT WOULDN’T IT BE NICE EVERY
NOW AND THEN IF GOOD NEWS OR
EVEN GOOD TRENDS WERE EMBRACED
BY BOTH PARTIES?
LOOK AT THIS GRAPH.
DEATH AND HOSPITALIZATIONS LOOK
LIKE THEY HAVE PEAKED IN
ARIZONA, GOING DOWN, THE LET’S
HOPE THEY KEEP DOING THAT.
THAT IS ACCORDING TO THE ARIZONA
REPUBLIC.
AND E.R. VISITS WITH SUSPECTED
COVID CASES HAVE BEGIN TO DROP.
VENTILATOR USES HAVE ALSO
DECREASED.
THE DEATH TOLL IN TEXAS PEAKED
AT 174 LAST WEEK AND HAS BEEN
TRICKLING DOWN SINCE THEN.
WE WILL LOOK FOR THE SAME TREND
IN FLORIDA LATER THIS WEEK.
BUT THE REASON WE CAN’T HAVE A
SERIOUS GROWN-UP CONVERSATION
ABOUT THIS IS BECAUSE EVERY TIME
SOME COUNTY AND SOME STATE HAS
AN UPTICK IN SOME INFECTION, THE
PRESS SCREAMS "IT’S ALL TRUMP’S
FAULT.
YOU SEE, WE OPENED UP TOO FAST!"
I’M HERE TO TELL YOU IT IS
CHILDISH AND STUPID.
SAME WITH PROMISING LOCKDOWNS
WON’T COST OUR COUNTRY DEARLY OR
PRETENDING WE CAN KEEP BORROWING
AND PRINTING MONEY TO COVER ALL
NONESSENTIAL SALARIES UNTIL THE
PANDEMIC IS GONE.
THAT IS CALLED MAILBOX MONEY.
TRY HIRING SOMEONE IN A
RESTAURANT TODAY.
WE NEED TO CAREFULLY EXAMINE
TRADE-OFF OF EVERY MOVE WE MAKE
IN RESPONSE TO THIS VIRUS.
THINK ABOUT IT.
DOCTORS FOCUS PRIMARILY ON ONE
THING: THE MEDICAL SIDE APPEAR
THAT IS WHAT THEY ARE TRAINED TO
DO.
BUT IT IS THE PRESIDENT’S JOB TO
FOCUS ON THE WHOLE COUNTRY.
OUR ELDERLY ARE NOW SUFFERING
ALONE.
OUR CHILDREN ARE SUFFERING BY
STAYING AT HOME.
PARENTS ARE WORRIED ABOUT HOW
THEY CAN POSSIBLY MANAGE IT ALL.
AND EMPLOYERS ARE BEGINNING TO
DO THE MATH AND THE NUMBERS ARE
UGLY.
AND OF COURSE, AMERICANS MOSTLY
THE ELDERLY ARE COMPROMISED, ARE
STILL TRAGICALLY SUCCUMBING TO
THE VIRUS.
BUT HERE, AS WE HAVE SHOWN YOU,
THAT DEATHS HAVE BEEN STEADILY
DECLINING SINCE THEIR PEAK IN
MARCH.
TRUMP’S APPROACH BEEN WISE.
HE COULDN’T LOSE THE ENTIRE U.S.
ECONOMY BY MANDATING A LOCKDOWN
OF 330 MILLION AMERICANS.
THAT WOULD HAVE BEEN RIDICULOUS,
ABUSIVE.
PLUS AS WE SAW IN MAY, THE
DEMOCRATS WERE FINE WITH
PROTESTERS WHO GATHERED BY THE
THOUSANDS, SOME OF THEM, BY THE
SMASHING UP THE PLACE IN
PORTLAND, OREGON.
THOSE ARE STILL BEING EXCUSED BY
THE LEFT, AND WE ARE BEING
CRITICIZED AS I MENTIONED
"HANNITY" FOR COVERING THEM.
>> THEY ARE REAL PROBLEMS IN
PORTLAND, BUT IT IS MADE UP ON
FOX NEWS LIKE IT IS THIS RAGING
FIRE OUT OF CONTROL.
AND THAT IS A GROSS
EXAGGERATION.
IT JUST IS A GROSS EXAGGERATION.
>> Laura: SO THE DEMOCRATS ARE
OFFERING FREE LOCKDOWNS AND IN
THE EXEMPTION FROM THE LOCKDOWNS
TO ANYONE WHO AGREES WITH THEM,
THEIR AGENDA.
NOW, YOU CAN SEE WHERE THAT
OFFER KIND OF WOULD HAVE BEEN
APPEALING TO FOLKS WHO REALIZE
LOCKDOWNS ACTUALLY CARRY IT IN
ENORMOUS COST THAT CAN BE MADE
UP WITH NEW WELFARE PROGRAMS.
I’M TALKING HUMAN COSTS, MORE
LIVES, OTHER ILLNESSES, NOT
ATTENDED TO.
IN REALITY, WE NEED A SERIOUS
AND WE NEED A BALANCED APPROACH
TO LOWER THE HARM CAUSED BY THE
VIRUS WHILE DOING THE BEST WE
CAN TO PROTECT THE ECONOMY, OUR
FAMILIES, OUR KIDS, AND OUR
SMALL BUSINESSES.
SO GOVERNORS IN PLACES LIKE
TEXAS AND FLORIDA TRIED THIS
MORE NUANCED APPROACH, AND IT
WILL NOT BE PERFECT, NOTHING IS.
BUT THEY HAVE BEEN MORE
SUCCESSFUL THAN THEIR
COUNTERPARTS IN NEW YORK,
CALIFORNIA, BY A LONG SHOT.
BUT IT IS HARD TO DEFEND AND
EXPLAIN THEY WANT SOMETIMES,
ISN’T IT?
MUCH EASIER TO SCREAM "WE NEED A
NATIONAL PLAN!"
SO THE VOTERS ARE TURNING
AGAINST THE G.O.P. BECAUSE THE
WHITE HOUSE HAS BEEN TELLING
THEM THREE THINGS THEY DON’T
WANT TO HEAR.
NUMBER ONE, OVER TIME, YOU CAN
ONLY BECOME PROSPEROUS BY
WORKING FOR IT, NOT BY BORROWING
MONEY OR PRINTING IT.
NUMBER TWO, YOU CAN’T CURE A
VIRUS BY SHUTTING DOWN YOUR
ECONOMY AND HIDING FROM IT.
AND NUMBER THREE, NO MATTER HOW
MUCH SYMPATHY YOU HAVE FOR YOUNG
PEOPLE, IT IS A MISTAKE TO
ENCOURAGE RIOTS AND LOOTING AND
THE DESTRUCTION OF PROPERTY.
NOW, THESE ARE THINGS A LOT OF
VOTERS MAY NOT WANT TO HEAR NOW.
AND REPEATING THEM MAY HURT THE
G.O.P. IN THE SHORT RUN.